few Hollywood films have caused as much
controversy as The Exorcist it's the at
Racal release in 1973 terrified and
outraged audiences with a grotesque tale
of demonic possession and despite barely
escaping an X rating it made history by
becoming the first horror film to earn a
Best Picture Oscar nomination it's still
considered one of the scariest movies
ever made with the intrigue surrounding
the Exorcist isn't limited to its shock
value in fact some of the most
compelling aspects of the movie come
from behind the scenes here are some
lesser-known facts about the classic
that's been turning heads for over 40
years
real-life basis believe it or not some
of the aspects of the Exorcist were
inspired by real events the film is
based on William Peter Blatty novel of
the same name which drew from accounts
of an actual exorcism according to the
New York Post most of the source
material for the book was called from
the journals of Jesuit priests who
documented an exhausting battery of
rituals they performed on a young boy
named Roland doe in 1949 these priests
claimed to have witnessed the boy
speaking in tongues mysterious skin
markings spelling the words hell and
evil the violent shaking of the boys
mattress and the breaking of hospital
restraints and a priest knows to name a
few some of the claims are admittedly
embellished in blad EES novel and the
film adaptation nobody spewed a bunch of
green vomit for example but still that's
pretty creepy church support it may come
as a surprise that many officials of the
Catholic Church were completely behind
the film's release not only did the drum
up plenty of interest in Catholic
tradition it highlighted Catholic
priests as heroes performing a
time-honored ritual even if that ritual
got a little repetitive the story goes
that one official even dug up some
classified documents for the Exorcist
while doing research for the film
director William Friedkin met with the
president of the Jesuit Georgetown
University who supposedly handed him a
folder containing eyewitness accounts of
the 1949 exorcism cursed production the
production of The Exorcist was riddled
with complications and tragedy early in
production the set depicting the home of
the MacNeil family mysteriously caught
fire delaying filming even more
mysterious the set for Reagan's
in which the exorcisms would be filmed
to remain completely undamaged many of
the cast and crew experienced tragedies
to Linda Blair's grandmother max von
sydow 's brother and two of the film's
actors died suddenly during the course
of production and Jason Miller's son was
nearly killed in a freak motorcycle
accident and then there were the
accidents on set Ellen Burstyn sustained
a spinal injury while filming a violent
possession scene which reportedly still
bothers her today as the unexpected
problems piled up the production
extended well past its projected
deadline freaking even had the set
blessed by a priest maybe he should have
gone for an exorcism while he was at it
wild release you'd have to be pretty
crazy to send death threats to a teenage
girl but that's exactly what some
religious folks did to Linda Blair after
the film was released in theaters hate
mail poured in accusing Blair of
glorifying Satan Warner Brothers had to
go so far as to hire bodyguards to
protect her after the film was released
and that's not the only bizarre
incidents surrounding the theatrical
release of the film a man fell and broke
his jaw during a screening claiming the
film subliminal effects caused him to
faint he sued the studio and they
settled out of court this was just one
of countless reports of paramedics being
called the theaters to treat terrified
moviegoers for hysterics anonymous demon
the demon that possesses Regan is called
Pazuzu but that name is never mentioned
in the original film despite being in
both the book and the production script
Pazuzu is a real issue man he's based on
a mythological Babylonian figure a king
of demon winds comprised of human and
animal parts father Merrin finds an
artifact in the desert at the beginning
of the film that is supposed to be a
portion of a Pazuzu statue while the
demon has seen it wouldn't be named
outright until the 1977 sequel The
Exorcist - The Heretic low-budget
effects the Exorcist may have been
unlike anything ever seen at the time
but Friedkin had to rely on some pretty
everyday effects to create the movie he
reportedly fired a gun before takes to
terrify the cast many scenes were shot
in freezing temperatures to maximize the
effect of actors breath and discomfort
on film that vomit fix split pea soup
the sound of Reagan projectile vomiting
was produced by a demonic voice actress
who regurgitated mushy apple and raw egg
and the creepy sound of Reagan's head
turning was nothing more than the sound
of a leather wallet being twisted in
front of a microphone it's so simple
it's
evil not a horror movie according to
Friedkin all these years of terror might
have been a case of mistaken intention
he told The Hollywood Reporter I thought
it was a film about the mystery of faith
but I didn't set out to make a horror
film but by now I've accepted that it is
that's a noble point of view but the
Exorcist sequels and prequels have kept
the franchise pretty squarely in genre
film territory that's all fine as long
as we don't have to watch anymore vomit
geysers thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]